welcome to the 2016 Henry Louis Gates Jr
annual lecture my name is Jacqueline
Goolsbee and I'm professor of English
and chair of Yale's African American
Studies department and on behalf of our
faculty students and staff I'd really
I'm so happy to see all of you here and
thank you for making the time to come
the gates lecture marks the capstone of
African American Studies academic year
not simply because the event literally
closes out our year of public
programming the Gates lectures are a
particular and special occasion for our
department because these talks give us a
chance to think incisively and
collectively with the entire Yale
community about the largest issues and
most decisive developments that shape
our fields of inquiry now four years old
this series has brought world leading
scholars and black diaspora studies to
Yale the philosopher Kwame Anthony
Appiah the dramatist poet critic and
Nobel laureate Wally shalinka
the legal theorist Patricia James J
Williams and today black feminist
theorist and literary critic Hortense J
Spillers they all come to share with us
their newest original work and in this
way
we honor the example of the scholar
after whom the series is named Henry
Louis Gates Jr whose pioneering literary
criticism theory and archival recovery
projects have been like our lecturers
scholarship foundational to
african-american and black diaspora
studies and indeed liberal liberal arts
inquiry is such to organize an event
like this requires a communal effort and
I want to give thanks to the Yale staff
colleagues and units that have made
today possible
in African American Studies our awesome
staff all of them
Jody Stewart Moore
Edith Rothkopf and especially Lisa
Monroe and Jeanette Sullivan they
deserve an awful large round of applause
for all of the work they've done over
these months to get us here today thank
you so much in the Provost's office
deputy Provost Emily Baek Meyer made
sure that we were threading the needles
and dotting the i's and crossing the t's
on our budget to make all of those dots
connected I want to thank her for her
help and advice and I also want to thank
Diane Witte our the university's
development office who's been very
generous and supportive of our work to
pull this event together and to make it
what we hope will be a special day for
us all Thank You Diane and I also want
to thank the University Library for
letting us use this wonderful space here
in Sterling Memorial Library it's
fitting to have this lecture here this
time given this thanks that we owe this
the lecture series main supporter Daniel
and Joanna Rose the Rose has created the
endowment that funds the gates lecture
series and I want to say to you how
honored we are that you've chosen to
support the work and the vision that we
carry for african-american studies at
Yale to this scale thank you so very
much for your support
and part of the reason why in this
particular instance it's fitting that
we're here at Sterling and mr. Rose is
here with us is that I want to
acknowledge his his family's long-held
commitment to education not only here at
Yale the family supports the Yale
libraries for turn off Holocaust
survivors video archive Rose walk the
passageway the plastic that the plaza
that we all crossed over to get into
this building the roses are also
supportive of educational initiatives in
the place they call home New York City
most notably mr. rose founded and as
chairman emeritus of the highly
acclaimed Harlem educational activities
fund whose black and Latino students are
flowing into the leading colleges and
universities across the US and I want to
thank you for that kind of activism on
behalf of the work we do here at Yale
African American Studies
and now to introduce today's
distinguished lecturer Hortense J
Spillers is the Gertrude Cano a
Vanderbilt professor of English at
Vanderbilt University she received her
PhD in English and American literature
from Brandeis University writing what
was in 1974 a path-breaking project
fabrics of history essays on the black
sermon over the course of her career she
has taught at Wellesley College
Haverford College the University of
Nebraska which must have taken special
fortitude Emory University the Free
University in Berlin Cornell University
and now Vanderbilt she is authored and
edited three books that are now
foundational texts in the fields of
African American Studies American
Studies and black feminist literary
studies conjuring black women fiction
and literary tradition co-edited with
Marjorie price published by Indiana
University Press comparative American
identities race sex and Nationality in
the modern texts selected papers from
the English Institute published by
Rutledge and black and white in color
essays on American literature and
culture published by the University of
Chicago Press this last work black and
white in color demonstrates pillars as
intellectual powers in their richest
light not simply because the essays
encompass a staggering range of literary
interests and theoretical fluencies in
my view this book commands attention
because with it Spiller's issues an
astounding argument for her particular
talent the art of the essay to explain
why I want to hone in on a particular
passage in the books introduction Peters
pans on eating in that he'd neither
eating in the Diaspora an essay that we
actually discussed in at lunchtimes
seminar in the department today here
Spiller's sharpens the Manifest theme of
this particular essay how food and food
ways can be studied semiotic ly as a
cultural trope of the African Diaspora
history and critical race studies while
a remarkable line of inquiry in
itself what's striking to me is how
Spillers suddenly discloses the
hermeneutics of her own prose style
substitute the essay for cuisine and
food in the following passage and
Spillers ingenuity as a theorist comes
shining forth with food we are both at
home and abroad a product of a
particular urban block or a spot of
provincial countryside and a world Ling
of multi languages and cultures I see no
need to choose as a material relations
and practice that inner economies
institutions and elementary bodies that
cross spaces borders and defenses that
permeate differences similarities and
commonalities that show the
intransigence of certain cultural values
at the same time that they exemplify
porosity and change the arts of the
cuisine offer a central metaphor for the
contact zone and our pluralist
possibilities the joining place of bread
and bread the feast that moves but can
also be still food always breeds a
politics a history bears publicness as
well as intimacy and represent ability
is visible yet the stuff whose
biochemistry like growing life remains
somehow mysterious and then the
translation makes a body glow and glow
in the cuisine contradiction comes home
and is not unhappy indeed the hallmark
of the Spillers essay is that
contradiction comes home and is not
unhappy if by contradiction we're
referring to the ways in which the essay
mode allows Miller's to enter economies
and institutions that cross spaces
borders and defenses that show the
intransigence of certain cultural values
at the same time that they exemplify
porosity and change the malleability of
the essay forms enriches Spillers style
of argument because the genres capacious
misled sir explore the full range of her
subjects boundaries Spiller's can be at
home and abroad in this mode since with
the essay she can say yes and no to it
wants to her own propositions thus
grounding her
berries and finely honed analytic
foundations this is the case in the
essay all the things you could be by now
is Sigmund Freud's wife was your mother
she also has a particularly talented
coming of a titles here Spillers
admittedly divided stance both for and
against classical psychoanalysis as a
proper paradigm to historic eyes racial
trauma leads to a revitalized method for
interpreting the dreamscapes of black
people in their life worlds there is of
course her remarkable intervention with
Mama's baby Papa's maybe an American
grammar book this 1987 essay which has
to be one of the most cited and
generative works in all of black
feminist theory proposed nothing less
than to Rican sieve the historiography
of slavery shifting critical attention
away from the over known claims
detailing the operations of racism's
political economy to the regimes then
less explained functions as a system of
gender domination Spiller's Wiis the
stunning analysis borrowing from Marx
and Freud's theories of identity
formation and the fetish to argue how
the particular institution how the
peculiar excuse-me institution deformed
the very idea of gender is an organizing
condition of the enslaves chattel status
a tour de force of argument this essay
stands with the works of Winthrop
Jourdan huge engine of AZ and Orlando
Patterson because it situates gender at
the nexus where the social death caused
by slavery occurs as these these three
examples suggest Spillers intellectual
creativity an archive of learning are
astonishing in the world is she
interprets it Edmund Morgan is lavash
Zija [ __ ] compatible light on the
history and meaning of slavery
multilingual Spillers herself recovers
and translates obscure French language
clinical studies of Senegalese youth to
test the capacities of Freud's Oedipus
theories in her essays on psychoanalysis
at home of the varieties of experience
literary critics called modernism
Spillers readily and Abele links the
aesthetics of Jean Toomer and William
Faulkner TS Eliot and Whittle and Brooks
Ralph Ellison and Kenneth Burke Alex
walk Alice Walker and Sigmund
Freud Toni Morrison and Mikhail Bakhtin
Paul Marshall and Immanuel Wallerstein a
prize-winning poet and this is a line
hidden on your CV she's also a radio DJ
and you'll hear this in her voice
early on in her career Spiller's comes
to language into literature to history
and art with a special year one that
allows her to discern unexpected
affinities within and across the life
worlds that black people inhabit with
others and create for themselves I
expect we will explore these ideas in
the lecture she'll deliver today shades
of intimacy what the 18th century
teaches us please join me in welcoming
our 2016 gates lecturer professor Horton
Spillers to Yale
oh my goodness
what an introduction I want to thank
Jackie Ghostly for that fabulous
introduction and for making this day
possible by extending this invitation to
me to be here today it's a great
pleasure to see you I also want to thank
mr. and mrs. Rose for their generosity
that makes this occasion possible and
thank you for being here today I know
there are a number of other places where
you could have been but you chose to be
here and I really appreciate it it's
probably been 10 years since I've been
on your beautiful campus I hadn't seen
the study before I think that's new it's
the only hotel and I have ever been in
that has a desk in it that works so that
whoever designed that hotel is really
brilliant they have a very good sense of
what human beings alike and that a desk
really should operate as as a desk
that's that's that's terrific I think
the last time I was here Calvin Warren
was a graduate student here before that
cedilla Hartman was a student in the
audience right so I've I've been here on
a few occasions it's great to be here to
see you today I'm getting over a little
bronchial thing Jackie did not tell me
that it was still cold in New Haven it's
quite hot in Nashville Tennessee so I
didn't necessarily come for late winter
so
if I tend to break up in a fit of
coughing I will I will try to recover by
having a little water I want to talk
today out of really what is a series of
notes on a subject that I have been
working on for a while now that really
is nowhere near a conclusion and as you
know it takes me a long time to get
things get things worked out shades of
intimacy
it's what I'm I'm calling this project
and it it gives its name to aspects on a
problematic really with with with no end
in sight and that that is huge and that
is to say what is the status of women in
the circumstances of revolution in
Europe or specifically the emergence or
the birth of the modern French state and
then two sites in the Americas in the
Caribbean of the French Antilles and Sun
domain in route to Haiti which is our
first modern black Republic and the
British colonies of North America on the
trajectory of what becomes the United
States the 18th century there's special
markings for us as these three sites are
exemplary because I believe that they
demonstrate with occasional clarity if
we can read the signs and I'm still
trying to learn to read the signs what
is at stake in the emergence of a
subject that we call today
a African diasporic or a subject who is
interstitial to African and new world
cultural forms IRA Berlin suggests that
the location of this subject in the
netherworld of coastal sub-saharan West
Africa those trading castles along the
West African coast yields a prototypical
hyphenated African subject I would call
it an interstitial subject who appears
to belong to the 18th century in
particular because his presence her
presence expresses the paradox or makes
the paradox appear of the world that
claims it wants freedom yet tolerates
slavery and at least a third of it this
is the era of the problem of slavery in
the Western world as David Ryan Davis
and other investigators have defined it
what does it mean to be human is evoked
with special acuity during the time of
revolution because the question entails
a historical apprenticeship that is not
limited to black personality but draws
humanity in its toils precisely because
what has counted as human is suddenly
transformed by the collapse of order and
degree if sovereignty for example comes
to ambiguously reside in a
representative symbolic figure as the
idea of democracy is strengthened then
its reverberations will be felt
throughout the socio-political order but
more than
that the contradictions born of the
simultaneity of slavery and freedom of
the absolute interpenetration of one and
the other are startling in their
apparently
Universal significance this weave of
relations is partially shrouded by the
public world of profit and production
just as it disappears into the shadowy
remoteness of the private world with its
masks of affection sentimentality and
cruelty the one word that seems to cross
this ambiguous and ambivalent territory
of public and private light and shade
production and reproduction could be
intimacy that registers the confusion
precisely because it is in this instance
neither fish nor fowl what do we call
the children born of sexual congress
between enslaved and their owners more
precisely the liaison between the
enslaved and their owners Douglas in his
1845 narrative observes what he regards
as a new social fact on the ground of
coercive labor and that is the sexual
work engendered in this calculus of
relations has produced what Douglass
calls the new people although such
children have appeared in Virginia
Colony even before the 18th century in
the story that Berlin tells about
communities that spring up along the
African littoral Douglas draws out this
strand of sociality
because he wants to emphasize the other
corruption of slavery's protocols
masters who own their children as such a
subject himself
Douglas was keenly aware of the
contradictions of his status that what
we call mixed-race today mixed-race
standing did not guarantee freedom even
as it enhanced the owners profits an
investigator is struck by the
epiphenomena of the new people not only
because of figures like Frederick
Douglas and Sally Hemings who was the
daughter and mother of interracial
crossing but also as these particulars
lead us to a broader inquiry about
intimate life in a world that allows
indeed enables both family in its
juridical privilege and personality and
extra familial life as the secret heart
of the families other the stuff of
novels in film as for example William
wells Brown Hotel or the president's
daughter will attest this familial
parallelism the family and the shadow
family is not an exception to the rule
as a matter of fact I'm beginning to
think that it might have been the rule
of slavery that it was not at all
exceptional I think when that fact was
born in on me actually not so long ago
it was it was it was quite stunning that
when we talk about morganatic marriages
and concubinage relationships we're
talking about something that is that is
quite quite common so it's not at all an
exception to the rule
and if it's not dominant and I think I
may be on the verge of saying that it is
it is at least a substantial arrangement
of slavery's generations across the
color line so what I hope to do
eventually is to extract from the record
a redefined and refined sense of
intimacy in a circumstance where flesh
becomes the medium of exchange because I
am convinced that even the master family
was not exempt from the brutalities of
slavery that they actually occur on the
ground of slavery if not fisticuffs in
binding certainly it's psychological
cruelties and I think that's the
question that I'm that I'm eventually
trying to ask how the enslavement of
African persons was actually a social
economy that affected everybody that was
involved in the system so that in fact
one wonders what we do with with the
topic of love under that under those
circumstances so the problematic that I
am attempting to isolate in this project
is how to name what happens at a depth
in the century of revolution we have a
fairly good sense of the spatio-temporal
sweep of the revolutionary art but what
I'm searching for tends to evade the
archives to disappear into the world of
the everyday if the shadow families of
the master class were defined by their
economic relations to the master then
how did this intrusion of money matters
reconfigure the whole range of
structures of feeling of official
intimate relations between
husbands and wives of the sibling
relationship in looking at this material
we are confronted by what I would call
two genres of historiography I would
call Annette Gordon reads worked on the
hemings's of Monticello for example and
I'm sure many people here are familiar
with that very substantial work it has a
prominent instance of what I would call
a positive assertion in the triad of
texts that she has produced so far and I
just saw the last one which is a study
of of Jefferson that just just recently
came out in that triad of texts that she
has produced so far on Sally Hemings as
liaison with Thomas Jefferson the
overall narrative that she advances
pursues the trope illogical fortunes of
what Toni Morrison has referred to as
the American romance of race in this
instance Hemings and her relatives are
given protective cover and a proximity
to Jefferson and his family that spares
them the more brutal realities of
enslavement this mode of historiography
resembles a kind of fictional writing as
in the case of Barbara chase rivers
Hemings
novels and as far as I can tell she
wrote two of them a couple of decades
ago that posits the seeds of intimacy
between master and enslaved in other
words the enslaved in this view of
things is constituted more or less as a
sexual object of desire
so that what we understand as love and
intimacy are not only possible between
master and enslaved but it is even
likely if you look at rebo's novel on
the character of Sally Hemings Sally
Hemings is in in love with the character
of Thomas Jefferson and so on the
question I would raise about that is
what is our investment in having the
story turn out that way
what is our investment in that
particular truth or that topological
procedure in the antithetical instance
the historiographical narrative paints a
very different picture that projects a
negative assertion for example in the
study of intimacy in the antebellum
South Steven stone argues that even the
most persistent and intimate contact
between masters and the bonded as in the
case of enslaved figures who like the
hemings's
worked as domestic servants in the
household of masters did not yield
intimacy between parties as Steven Stowe
describes it intimacy in the antebellum
South was aligned with public forms and
perception as expressed in rituals of
courtship such rituals assured the
acknowledgement of an intimate relations
unfolding so that the ritual form became
a kind of knowledge or epistemology
distributed among members of a class
which bespeaks a sharing of values so
this very private thing in our world
between and among lovers which we
relegate in the shareable imaginary to
the private and domestic sphere if those
terms still work I'm not sure they do
but in any case those lovers in snows
conceptual narrative are assigned to the
world of public forms and performance
why does the difference matter or how
does the difference matter if close
proximity or constant contact does not
guarantee intimacy in this social order
then it seems to me that our notions of
intimacy and chains of intimacy are
thrown into crisis I would have to admit
that this question gets sharper for me
as as time passes in a twentieth-century
cinematic instance drove home to me a
little bit more of what I was trying to
when I was trying to get at I'm sure
that a lot of people here saw 12 years
of slave right and read the narrative 12
years of slave it actually took me two
years to get to the movie I did not I
had read the narrative some time ago and
recognized that it was not just
discovered by somebody in Britain just a
few years ago I mean I've known that
story for a very long time but I was
afraid to go to see what I actually had
to see in the movie you will recall the
juxtaposition of two scenes right and
this is the work of film editing of
course but then we also imagine that
something like that actually happened
quite a lot in real life the scene where
one of the protagonists is beaten takes
place the night after the master has
been in the person's bed right so this
is what I'm talking about when I asked
the question about what what intimacy or
close proximity promises or guarantees
in the social order and in this case it
seems to me that it guarantees nothing
okay so if proximity is not reliable as
a measure of social cohesion if sexual
partners and their children can be sold
off
if shadow families can assert no claims
to the human dignity of official
families then sentimentality and
feelings of love can be shown to be
unstable
I believe everywhere did slavery
across the Western world rupture ties of
kinship and filiation so completely at
the 18th century and possibly earlier
demolishes what Constance Classen in the
deepest sense a cultural history of
touch called a tactile cosmology when in
an earlier piece of writing I sought a
distinction between body and flesh I was
attempting to isolate features of
citizen belonging from alien bodies and
entities I would associate bonded nakum
personality or the historical actor or
agent
who has access to what our 14th
amendment calls due process under its
impress at least in theory other rights
bearing follows flesh describes an alien
entity a more or less expendable figure
not only does the alien who can be an
alien in some ways arbitrarily by race
or language or culture and custom not
only does the alien not have access to
the protocols of due process but perhaps
it's most poignant determination is the
extent to which such a body cannot
prevent a reward of another's touch so
for me the single most powerful evidence
of the loss of freedom is the fact that
bodies lose their integrity and may be
invaded or entered so to speak by
coercive power this touch that we
associate with intimacy can under the
right conditions engender invasion and
violence and in its immediacy in
relationship to the enslaved Rob's the
haptic of its powers to heal to bind to
cure and becomes instead the power to
wound and violate here's another note
from classic quote in the sensory scale
of races created by the natural
historian lawrence oaken the civilized
European I
who focused on the visual world was
positioned at the top and the African
skinned man who used touch as his
primary sensory modality at the bottom I
am suggesting that under slavery's
regimes the captive body's
susceptibility to being touched or
manhandled places this body on the side
of the flesh so that touching here is
not a token of social cohesion as
Classen describes it in the period
preceding the modern age of brotherhood
or fellowship or a fellow feeling but
rather the very breadth and depth of
alienation among other things from the
laws and perhaps even ways of
distinguishing human life from their
life or animal life so that I have begun
to wonder what the touch ability of the
enslaved had to do with the kind of
public relations that followed those
publications those populations right I
mean what kind of stories were
circulated about that humanity that was
subject to to touch even from strangers
the leading descriptive features of
slavery's eras tend to be economic as we
know in the most pointed sense of the
term balance sheets and the counting
procedures gains losses profit margins
in the flow of goods while our most
sustained focus on the institution and
its practices come to rest on what
Pierre Bourdieu might have called a
general science
on the economy of practices in other
words the argument that is based on
narrow economic considerations defines
the enslaved as a species of property by
contrast the argument that seeks to
mobilize an understanding of the
position of the enslaved and of the
world that unmake him or her as a
competitive instance of a general
science of an economy of practices
attempts to grasp the circumstance of
the bonded as a type of historical
subjectivity in both the species of
property and a type of historical
subjectivity we recognize in their very
naming the ambivalence of status that
would prohibit either from standing in
as a pure or a legible example of
property or a purely unfor closed
instance of the subject of history which
revolutionary movement seeks to create
neither embodies the paradigmatic norm
from which deviation might be gauged the
enslaved then is already a category
mistake whose subject begins his/her
human Odyssey in paradox as a mark or an
inscription of the paradoxical dilemma
that exposes irreconcilable or in
commensurate postures we might think of
slavery then for the enslaved as a
series of gaps or aporia's of which even
the slave holder himself is aware
generating parallel contradictions given
his his other dread
the definitive police power an extension
of his own dominance and the force of
law are not enough the fascinating
spectacle of moral and political jujitsu
that colonial power dances around the
dilemma of the enslaved for instance
Jefferson splitting of the difference
between the simultaneously held beliefs
in gradual emancipation and black
repatriation or the long train of
abolitionist thinkers who embrace the
principle of emancipation yet believe at
the same time that the African is far
less human and socialized about than
others or yet across the revolutionary
terrain the colonialists rhetorical
appropriation of the discourses of
liberation in their own behalf while
denying the legitimate human claims of
the enslaved all reflected the tensions
unleashed by the Africans ontological
status as the confounding of human and
proprietary aims and identities
mixed-race or mulatto nests belongs to
this calculus of contradictions the
available racial ascriptions of
Jeffersons and Hemings as world are as
inadequate and flawed as the concept of
race itself interstitial to the
allegedly fixed postures of black and
white the Milanoo is consigned to a
liminal space that is dragged alone at
least in the u.s. instance as an
unresolved figure of slavery's closure
although as we've already noted one
neither nor does not save her from the
arbitrary and whimsical reflexes of
power that defined the behavior of the
Masterclass
Sally Hemings in the particular instance
embodies a supplementary dilemma insofar
as her supposed erotic relationship to
the Empowered or erotic in the American
romance of race and erotic is a
troublesome term here positions her
within the precincts of sentiment as
sentimentality plays out among the
hemings's two generations of children
born to enslaved women carried the
mother's last name this defining
children by the name and status of the
mother is instrumental to the overriding
significance of property rights and the
laws of inheritance though erratically
involved with power and herself the
product of such an engagement Sally
Hemings was not manumit by her famous
owner during his lifetime but her
children would be and that Gordon read
notes that only a handful of Jefferson's
considerable population of enslaved
people's hundreds of people I think made
something like five or six hundred some
historians have said that only a handful
of members of this population was let go
before his death and that all of these
were Hemings is
it could be said then that the social
distance that we perceived between black
and white may the location of the color
line strikingly clear while the mulatto
figure falling a brought the difference
sustains no legally defined social
identity Sally Hemings is roughly
analogous to women of the Masterclass
quite specifically this does not mean
all white women rather it defines
precisely women of the Masterclass
insofar as she like they following Amy
drew Stanley's analysis remained within
households bound together by ties of
affection though admittedly we cannot be
sure about the affection piece if white
women who embodied the concept of sex
difference gained no individual
entitlements in relationship to contract
theory and practice which came to take
the place of relations of dominance and
subservience then their deficiency of
juridical personality was predicated on
the fact that they were quote part of
the family protected by neither the
heroics of masculinity as black men
would be in gaining the franchise nearly
a century leader nor the prerogatives of
sentimentality as women of the master
class would be African women of the
Republican era fall outside the
disposable subject positions as
interstitial Sally Hemings but for
different reasons that the documents of
the era make available the Haitian
Constitution of 18 five offers an
interesting contrast
their lack of juridically defined
personality except in negative cases
exposes the fundamental ability or yeah
lay bility is is the word I want I guess
liability as well and change ability of
free and enslaved in other words what
comes to be reified as natural to the
identity of white males turns out to be
the subject of risk and negotiation in
in other cases in effect black women
customarily and emphatically not Sally
Hemings as fiction and historiography
imagine her can only broach the
territory of the human as members of a
race just as their brethren and their
entire historical apprenticeship as a
result is contextualized on the muddy
ground that falls between sexes gender
distinctions on the one hand and race
difference on the other between the
private realm and the erotic on the one
hand that depends on sex gender
difference and the public realm and the
historical on the other that is
predicated on race difference the
Equality that is evoked in the founding
documents the Declaration of
Independence the Declaration of the
Rights of Man and the citizen and the
constitutions of Haiti the 18 2 and 18 5
constitutions all emanate from the
notion of the self willing self owning
one whose interest in property is now a
matter of law another like himself is
neither more nor less than he as access
to markets and money and the law
arbitrate between and among legal
personnel
tee's Amy drew Stanley in the work from
bondage to contract provides a link
between changing attitudes about labour
sentiments about freedom and equality
and the blossoming movement of
emancipation that is tied to the
revolutionary ideal transitory and
fleeting the contractual relationship
did not extend beyond its reason for
being and for some observers the world
of contract is solidly set over and
against the sentimental realm or the
realm of feeling belonging to the sphere
of private and personal relations
sentiment is opposed to contract and
comes to describe woman's sphere and
it's grammars of feeling including
sexual and erotic gestures that mark it
off from the public world of action over
things the sphere of the Jewish
Prudential as the slavery debate
intensifies and proceeds through the
decades that lead up to the Civil War
contract theory plays a crucial role in
configuring conceptualizations
engendered by the abolitionist campaigns
Stanley even goes so far as to contend
that contract became the language of
insurgent popular politics and that much
of the force of its appeal was adopted
from African woman's new world
experience and two key principles
obtained here
one of them is that slavery denies
contractual ability that's a part of the
due process in the enslaved but even
before that the slave is divested of
self ownership
cap hazards of the haptic that I was
talking about a moment ago divested of
self-ownership and therefore must suffer
the convoy of evils that follows in the
wake of such deficiency the experience
of slave women under slavery's regimes
advances the notion of a double threat
insofar as they were vulnerable to
sexual torture and abuse as well as the
repertory of normative discipline and
punishment that attaches to the travails
of violently coerced labor not that the
male did not endure the same regimes but
I would argue that the rights of the
master of the household placed women in
powers orbit in systematically
provocative ways the sexual abuse and
use of black women and slavery was the
rule hemming is his mother
for instance birth some twelve children
maybe more half of them children with
the black father the other half children
with the white father so trapped in
imminence and the life of the species
these females essentially repeat animal
life with no horizon beyond it this
motif is scored into the fabric of
everyday life for bonded women and under
the circumstance it was neither shocking
nor unexpected to the coeval world that
they would have been so Stanley contends
that the flesh of female slaves thus
took center stage in abolitionist
propaganda we recall that it is
discouraged body of the bonded woman
that we most vividly remember as does
Douglass himself from the latter's 1845
narrative and the powerful tale of
flight
in the avoidance of sexual persecution
that animates the long and torturous
journey of Harriet Jacobs and accounts
tinged with eroticism drew Stanley
argues abolitionists across the race
divide evoked a corporeal slave economy
that was diametrically opposed to the
sexual order of free society in which
female purity as Harriet Jacobs pleads
her case was valued as a priceless
possession in short bonds women
subjected to the tortures of the flesh
in the discipline of the sexual and
laboring body become the quintessential
image of the terrors of the peculiar
institution under such conditions it
seems that the erotic and the sexual are
meaningless except that we recognize
them by their absence not protected by
the ties of sentiment which could be
interrupted for any reason often
narrowly economic as we pointed out the
enslaved confronted in her person what
living was in the absence of love and
sex beyond naked copulation not only
this but the very withdrawal of private
and privacy as a human right at the same
time that the bonded woman belonged to
public history only insofar as she was
the ambiguous subject owned like things
by others what our writers and
historians have paid imaginative witness
to is the fact that there is no human
loneliness and aloneness remotely calm
to that of the enslaved beyond the reach
and scope of love and freedom beyond
touch that is a token of care of concern
for care the day that the enslaved
decides to act out the threat of death
that always hangs over her by risking
her life is the first day of wisdom as
Toni Morrison promises and whether or
not one survives it is perhaps less
important than the recognition that
unless one is free love cannot and will
not matter thank you
talk with a thing so thank you dr.
Spillers given the the lovely
introduction that we got from Professor
Goolsbee about the way in which you've
innovated and revolutionized the form of
the essay I'm wondering if you could
talk to us a little bit about how the
theories of intimacy that you challenged
us with in in this particular piece how
they're mobilized in a particular way in
the form of the essay for you or how you
think about theories of intimacy and how
you formalistic aliy construct the essay
I don't know if I'm you know I've just
I'm always struck by and again professor
Goolsbee
really laid it out so just gorgeously
what you're able to aesthetically as
well as theoretically explore within
your scholarship at the level of form as
well as content and so I'm I guess in
this particular piece and I'm interested
in how you're thinking about intimacy as
it formalistic aliy works out in in the
piece you know I have ideas but I'm
interested in how you your writing
process and working through this very
difficult revisitation of these issues
that we continue to struggle with in our
everyday work as black feminists
I was saying that this came up should I
give you mine okay can you hear me yeah
this came up at at lunch today in the
form of a question about the memoir as a
place that some academic writing is
going and I was I was thinking about
that in relationship to my own work
which in and the way is as always a
memoir I mean it's it's always my work
is always inflected through
something that I am paying close
attention to in in an intimate or
personal way at the moment so that from
that point of view I've never really
detached from the thing that that I'm
writing and I think what I'm trying to
do in writing is get the feeling on the
page right I think I'm trying to show
how a particular question really does
have implications for me as a writer
which is when I suggest to my students
all the time but the stuff that that
we're reading and writing about is not
something out there somewhere it has
something to do with with us with
ourselves right there are implications
for us in the work that we do and so I
think that's yes no thank you I mean I
just I I would add to that for me as a
listener that I feel as though you so
brilliantly in virtuosic least age a
kind of presumptive epistemological
intimacy that you then overturn in your
work I don't know if that you know it's
you you so intricately are able to map
out these constructs that seem so
familiar to us and then turn them on
their head and I think at the level of a
formalistic detail it's really powerful
in terms of trying to stay to a
reimagining of how we think about
history and historiography so thank you
once again you know I always think that
if we don't solve a problem we're going
to die so that that's how it fails
that's how it feels listening to you so
thank you
does this work okay for another
brilliant intervention I mean this is
just it's really amazing work I've been
thinking a lot and part of the reason I
wanted to come here today was I've been
thinking a lot about the 18 second you
give me yet another way to think about
the 18th century which is
extraordinarily fruitful I'm one of the
I guess that there's so many things I
want to say but one that I want to ask
is I was reading recently about Harriet
Martineau and particularly this idea
that she develops in the 19th century
that the in some ways the absence of
public prostitution in the South
especially gives rise to some of the
kinds of violence and abuse precisely
that you're talking about that that sort
of easy access to slave women's bodies
in the absence of a kind of and for all
kinds of reasons religious level but
otherwise but gives rise to a lot of the
kind of violence that of course also
then increases the slaveholders since
slaves follow the condition of the
mother literally increases also his
economic bottom line so I I mean in
thinking through her and listening to
you today I wonder if there's anything
you'd want to say in particular about
that the this notion of a kind of
absence of this idea public prostitution
and religiosity because I that's the one
thing that I was expecting to hear from
you a little bit today about religion
because there is this there's all kinds
of contradictions of that introduces as
well but I want you to say a little bit
more
a little bit about how that also sort of
works into this idea of these domestic
affections that get disrupted in this
way that you're that you're talking
about so beautifully
okay um so I am dwelling on your last
words unless one is free love cannot and
will not matter and so you began talking
through the complete kind of
interpenetration of slavery and freedom
so the I chose ideas about freedom so I
guess what I'm asking then is is sort of
whose love is that like who's if if the
free part of the first part of that
statement unless one is free then love
cannot and will not matter like his love
also how how is that being constructed
is that another is are you trying to
sort of unsettle some construction of
love that accompanied the construction
of freedom does that make sense
I don't know if I'm making if the one
term is problematic and you're troubling
a lot then what does that mean for the
other
yeah
The Histories
and
in nature
itself is also
Plato
very
which the Masterclass the suffering if
the social order wasn't created by
tyranny you know everyone